et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
bruno retailleau bonjour donc merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous sénateur de la
vendée président du groupe l'est
républicain car ici au sénat on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représenté par
christelle bertron du groupe la dépêche
bonjour christelle jorian bonjour une
orgie you et bruno rose à lyon va
commencer en parlant de jean michel
blanquer est sous le feu des critiques
il s'est exprimé hier soir au 20h de tf1
sous le feu des critiques parce qu'il a
annoncé le nouveau protocole sanitaire
depuis son lieu de vacances à ibiza
alors lui il dit que ça n'aurait rien
changé qu'il soit york il a travaillé
durant les 4 jours de vacances qu'il a
pris et que certes si c'était à refaire
il choisirait une autre destination vous
avez été convaincu par ces explications
est ce que pour vous il ya une faute
politique de la part de jean-michel
bancaire dont les reproches que j'ai à
faire à jean michel blanquer c'est pas
tellement d'avoir pris ces décisions à
ibiza ou ailleurs les deux reproches que
j'ai à faire c'est d'avoir pris d'abord
de mauvaises décisions d'avoir créé une
pagaille une panique pour les familles à
l'école avec ce protocole annoncées la
veille pour le lendemain changer trois
fois en l'espace de quelques jours
c'était la grande pagaille c'est le
premier reproche et le second reproche
que je lui fais c'est la feuille de
l'école française le bilan de jean
michel blanquer ce sera quoi finalement
ce sera toujours une grande proportion
plus de 20% des élèves qui rentrent en
sixième qui ne maîtrise pas les maths
qui maîtrisent pas le français c'est un
bac es totalement
dévalorisé à tel point notamment sur les
mathématiques puisque désormais en
terminale il y a que 41 % des élèves qui
font encore des maths comment voulez
vous demain compte construire une nation
d'ingénieurs alors que tant de défis
scientifiques technologiques nous
attendent et malheureusement nous avons
dégringolé depuis des années 2000 nous
avons dégringolé de 22 points dans les
classements internationaux en maths en
lecture de 12 points c'est ça la
réussite de jean michel blanquer qu'on
nous avait présenté comme le nouveau
jules ferry des mails macron non ce sont
ces deux reproches lubie
c'est par leur essai de la péripétie
franchement la politique mérite mieux
allons aux actes allons aux fêtes et aux
décisions
je ne demande jamais une démission je ne
hurle jamais avec les loups et en plus
c'est une facilité quand vous demandez
une des missions vous savez parfaitement
que la démission c'est pas vous qui l'a
décidé c'est d'autres qui la décide donc
on ne doit jamais essayé de de prendre
des décisions quand d'autres cantons
peut pas la prendre c'est quand ce elle
dépend d'autres personnalités excusez
moi d'insister mais c'est vrai que
beaucoup lui reprochent de ne pas avoir
été là alors la veille d'une rentrée
scolaire qui s'annonçait extrêmement
difficile dans son bureau auprès des
enseignants ça avait été beaucoup
reproché jean-françois métayer à
l'époque de la canicule de ne pas être à
paris dans son bureau les temps changent
et entre hier et aujourd'hui non c'est
simplement vous voyez bien le débat
politique aujourd'hui qui est à la fois
violent et qui je trouve se perd dans
des faux fuyants finalement dans des
choses qui sont qui relève de
l'accessoire le principal c'est sa
gestion qui n'a pas été anticipée de du
protocole de la crise épidémique moi je
réclame depuis des mois par exemple les
capteurs co2 l'état 10 97 aux
collectivités non c'est un problème de
santé publique qui doit être uniforme
sur le tout le territoire et je pense
que c'est à l'état de prendre les moyens
j'ai je me suis fait équiper dans mon
bureau au sénat d'un capteur 0 2 a coûté
80 euros et bien dès lors que la science
nous a appris que c'est les aérosols qui
propage la contamination pourquoi est-ce
qu'on n'a pas équipé toutes nos salles
de classe michel blanc car a dit jeudi
dernier qu'il allait aborder le fond
pour vous sa plume il ya un an qu'on le
dit voyez ce gouvernement aura manqué
d'anticipation
surtout sur les lits aussi d'hôpitaux il
ya de moins en moins de lits parce qu'il
ya de moins en moins de personnel
soignant le ségur de la santé c'est plus
10 milliards cette année vous savez ce
qu'en dit la cour des comptes la cour
des comptes a dit dans un rapport au
mois de septembre que dans ses murs de
la santé il ya un angle mort c'est le
service selon le service de réanimation
et soins critiques vous rendez compte
alors que ce sont avec ses services
quand pilote en france la politique
sanitaire ça veut dire que vous soutenez
la grève des enseignants demain moi j'ai
pas l'habitude de soutenir les grèves
parce que ça va mettre dans la barre a
beaucoup beaucoup de familles parce
qu'il peut y avoir d'autres moyens
d'exprimer un désaccord
pardon je ne fasse j'ai pas l'habitude
de soutenir
qu'est ce qu'ils ont comme souvent rien
ne la soutient pas mais je la comprends
voilà en termes clairs un mot sur le
passe à l'acte final puisque on a appris
hier qu'il y avait un record de
contamination en france 2 400 près de 4
65 mille cas qui ont été enregistrées
vous avez voté le passé actional est ce
que c'est la bonne solution quand on
voit l'ampleur actuelle de l'épidémie on
sait qu'un vacciner peut être contaminé
contaminants est-ce que vu l'ampleur de
la vague il ne valait pas mieux
réimposer les tests au moins pendant
cette période donc moi je pense que le
pass vaccinale est une âme c'est une
arme parce que elle est décisive pour
les formes graves de la maladie qu'est
ce que nous dit je parlais des services
de réanimation qu'est ce que nous dit la
société française des réanimateurs des
anesthésistes c'est eux qui sont au
chevet de ses malades là et bien ils
nous disent que sur 165 hôpitaux qu'ils
ont pu tester en france 80% des malades
qui sont dans ces services de soins
critiques n'ont pas été vaccinés voilà
les choses sont très claires et donc le
vaccin est une arme mais je me distingue
du gouvernement je pense que ça ne doit
pas être la seule arme je pense que
larmes de l'anticipation je parlais pour
les écoles des capteurs de co2 pour
éviter les contaminations je parlais de
la politique de l'ide hospitalière
c'est presque un effondrement et mails
macron nous avait promis des milliers de
lits supplémentaires en fait on en a
moins qu'il y en avait sans doute il y
annonce on aurait dû aussi avoir une
politique presque de porte à porte pour
les quatre cent mille personnes âgées de
plus de 80 ans qui ne sont pas vaccinés
pour ceux qui sont plus jeunes mais avec
des fragilités avec les médecins
traitants il aurait fallu avoir une
opération massive parce que c'est eux
qu'il faut d'abord protéger donc oui au
vaccin donc oui oh pas actional mais
c'est une arme parmi d'autres mon
reproche là aussi même si je sais qu'il
faut être humble modeste mais mon
reproche c'est qu'on a toujours eu un
temps de retard voyez alors vous n'avez
pas été suivi par l'assemblée vous au
sénat sur ce texte sur deux points
particuliers les contrôles d'identité
les amendes dues par les autres ce qui
ne respecteraient pas tout à fait les
règles j'ai envie de vous demander à
quoi sert le sénat à quoi servait le
sénat dans ce débat là si je pense qu'on
a été suivi sur un certain nombre de
points pas sur tous les points y'a pas
vous n'avez pas souligner nous avions
souhaité dans le premier article
soumettre le pass vaccinale à des
indicateurs parce que nous ce qu'on veut
c'est qu'on ne veut pas que cet
instrument dur dans la permanence on
veut que lorsque l'épidémie aura des
crues on veut que le pass vaccinale soit
caduc les députés ne nous ont pas suivis
qu'est ce que nous allons faire qu'est
ce que nous allons faire nous allons
discuter cet après midi en conférence
des présidents l'idée pourrait être par
exemple et plusieurs idées mais de
confier des pouvoirs de commission d'
enquête à la commission des affaires
sociales du sénat qui vérifierait
semaine après semaine les indicateurs
épidémiologique pour dire au
gouvernement très bien on a besoin de
cet outil qu'est le pass vaccinale ont
la beauté tant qu' on est constructif on
est positive mais quand cet outil-là
sera devenue disproportionnée ne sera
plus nécessaire alors il faudra
l'arrêter on ne peut pas vivre en france
dans une société du contrôle permanent
quand l'épidémie le réclament alors oui
on déplace le curseur c'est ce que nous
avions fait sur un tout autre champ sur
le terrorisme par exemple il avait fallu
mettre le curseur un peu plus du côté de
la sécurité vis-à-vis des libertés on
l'a fait aussi dans une crise épidémique
mais quand les choses ne sont plus
nécessaires alors de grâce de grâce
faisons en sorte que ça devienne caduc
il y aura au sénat la mise en place
d'une commission d' enquête sur le suivi
d'applications que ce pas actional ça
signifie parce que on a une collégialité
voilà par bruno retailleau qui décident
j'ai échangé avec d'autres présidents de
groupe voilà pas forcément de mon bord
du reste ça veut dire que à la
conférence des présidents de cet après
midi c'est une des voies que nous
discuterons les autres les autres cette
voie là ma préférence eh bien ils
s'exprimeront je peux vous dire que en
tout cas plusieurs passages échange de
celle consulter je pense que ça a des
chances alors la conférence des
présidents en parle d'inscrits et
ensuite c'est votée dans l'hémicycle
c'est l'attribution à la commission des
affaires sociales des pouvoirs de la
commission denquête pourquoi cet
intéressant passe ceux qui viennent et
qui sont auditionnés s'ils mentent ils
tombent sous le coup d'un article du
code pénal ça doit les inciter à dire
éric là ça veut dire que vous au 10e ne
riez des professeurs des représentants
des hôpitaux pour déminer une idée des
critères c'est pas à moi de faire ce
sera la présidente de la commission des
affaires sociales catherine de roche et
puis au rapporteur qu'elle désignera qui
seront désignés de faire ce choix c'est
pas un président de groupe placé les
commissions du sénat sont des
commissions institutionnels elle
travaille en toute indépendance et les
critères seront décidés de la même
manière les critères nous les avions
déjà des files défini je pense que c'est
philippe bas qui avaient porté un
amendement à la commission des lois dont
l'idée vous comprenez bien l'idée c'est
pas de fliquer le gouvernement l'idée
c'est simplement qu' on puisse s'assurer
dans une autre enceinte que le
gouvernement c'est ça la démocratie
c'est des pouvoirs et des
contre-pouvoirs que le pass sanitaires
ils durent jusqu'à ce que ce soit
nécessaire quand il n'est plus
nécessaire alors il s'éteint sauf que le
parlement il n'est pas sensé siéger
entre mars et des bougies est ce que ça
veut dire que vous viendrez quand même
je dis ici à public sénat que la
différence entre le sénat et l'assemblée
nationale c'est que le sénat est une
assemblée permanente nous ne sommes pas
renouveler pourquoi nous sommes
renouveler d'ailleurs par moitié tous
les trois ans ça nous permettent de
continuer en permanence de ne pas nous
interrompre l'assemblée elle il va y
avoir des nouvelles élections ce n'est
pas une assemblée permanente mais nous
on travaille et on assure la permanence
voiliers de la république en ait le
soutien de l'afd soutient la république
c'est aussi l'utilité du sénat
oui le conseil constitutionnel a annoncé
rendre sa décision vendredi
socialistes et insoumis ont eu raison de
le saisir je pense que il ya toujours
intérêt à saisir le conseil
constitutionnel
je ne suis pas certain nous l'avons nous
avons réfléchi pensé je suis pas certain
à ce que va donner ce contrôle du
conseil constitutionnel mais pour les
libertés publiques que c'est important
on va parler d'un texte qu'ils étaient
menés cet après-midi dans l'hémicycle
celui renforçant le droit à l'avortement
oui
a été voulu par par la majorité
aujourd'hui vous vous avez par le
gouvernement et par le gouvernement
parce que le même bac rendu à 10 90
c'est brutal c'est ça peut être
traumatisant mais en fait c'est dans une
niche du gouvernement donc la saison car
tu vois là sur le plan politique ces
tartuffes il ya eu un petit jeu en
disant non mais l'elysée veut pas et
c'est la majorité parlementaire non non
ça ne se serait pas discuter sans que le
gouvernement est ouvert un créneau dans
l'agenda
entre ce qu'ils vivent ces doubles
langages
6,5 en faut voilà je crois qu'on connaît
belle macro le en même temps c'est ça le
même temps c'est à double langage voilà
blanc noir le jour le lendemain faut s'y
habituer le groupe bel air va s'y
opposer pour quelle raison on va s'y
opposer on va s'y opposer pour des
raisons médicales tout simplement parce
que quand on passe de tout semaine à
quatorze semaines 16 semaines
d'aménorrhée l'améliorer c'est à partir
de l'association des règles eh bien
quand je parle de changement nature
c'est que il ya par exemple
l'ossification du foetus on passe du
stade de l'embryon au foetus et beaucoup
de médecins la société par exemple
l'académie de médecine mais la société
française des obstétriciens-gynécologues
indiqué que c'est traumatisant et même
le professeur disant vous savez je
l'écoutais l'autre jour dans une chaîne
qui est concurrente lui avait milité
pour le passage de dix semaines à 12
semaines il dit là franchement non c'est
pas possible et dis moi il y avait
quelque chose que je n'avais pas
anticipé il ya vingt ans quand on est
passé de 10 à 12 semaines c'est que ça
décourage et un très très grand nombre
d'obstétriciens de pratiquer cet acte
qui devenait est un acte beaucoup moins
anodin donc oui nous nous y opposons
mais vous savez pour un certain nombre
de militants se sera jamais assez il
vous réclame 14 semaines alors que c'est
une intervention extrêmement brutale
notamment sur le foetus dont il faut des
membres et bill compris la tête parce
que il ya une sofica sion mais ils nous
demanderont après 14 semaines 16
semaines et on nous dira oui mais à
l'étranger et à cette semaine ya dix
sept semaines donc non je pense que il
ya des limites oui à la voyais de l'eau
a jailli bien sûr mais dans des limites
qui doit tenir compte d'un certain
nombre
justement de considération éthique et
médical là aussi bien sur les espoirs
mois la proposition est faite justement
parce qu'il ya de gros problèmes de
délais parce qu'à des problèmes
d'effectif et des femmes qui se
retrouvent piégées et qui ne peuvent pas
voilà alors cette audience rennes
d'accès alors est-ce bien sûr piège pas
un petit peu les femmes en allongeant
parlant bien même les délais non il ya
un problème d'accès vient le problème
d'accès etc c'est absolument clair mais
vous verrez que si jamais ce texte était
voté je ne l'espère pas et bien il y
aurait encore moins de médecins à
pratiquer il y aura encore plus on le
dit choix d'accès bien sûr mais c'est
pas moi qui le dit c'est le professeur
nisand connaissez le monde et sur dean
il a milité pour le passage des 10
semaines 12 semaines il a très
clairement dit je suis contre cette
mesure et moi ce que je n'avais pas
anticipé il ya vingt ans c'est que il y
aurait des difficultés et cela
découragerait parce que l'acte devient
un acte beaucoup plus sérieux beaucoup
plus intrusif sa découragerait des
médecins de pratiquer les vg l'autre
actualité ces
européens les maltaise conservatrice
opposée notamment à lille et j'ai ce que
c'est un bon signal qu'envoie l'union
européenne écoutez elle est élue est par
ailleurs ces questions là ne ressorte ce
pas de la compétence de l'union
européenne donc voilà il est élu es et
elle est élue ça n'est pas le pouvoir du
parlement européen de dire oui ou de
dire mon arrivée j'ai je pense que si un
aussi grand nombre de députés européens
lente et lui c'est parce qu'ils savent
parfaitement que l'europe a des
compétences sur un certain nombre de
points elle n'a pas sur d'autres et la
question par exemple de ivg comme
d'autres questions restent des questions
purement nationale emmanuel macron
justement et au parlement européen ce
matin il pas son grand oral devant les
députés il va fixer les grandes lignes
de la présidence française du conseil de
l'union européenne qu'est ce que vous
attendez de son discours pas pas grand
chose parce que j'ai l'habitude non je
vais vous dire pourquoi d'abord parce
que on a l'habitude de l'écart avec
mails macron entre les grands discours
des beaux discours qui parfois mon touch
est d'ailleurs mis là il a ce talent là
d'un talent oratoire qu'il faut lui
reconnaître alors quel écart entre le
discours et les actes que reste-t-il de
son grand discours de la sorbonne a t-il
réussi par exemple sur le salaire
minimum en europe non at il réussi à
transformer la directive travailleurs
détachés non puisque les cotisations
sociales sont toujours payés par le dans
le pays d'origine regardez sur la
question aux migrations valérie pécresse
était ce week end en grèce la grèce a
divisé par huit le nombre des
clandestins elle a fait une barrière
physique avec des centres de rétention
mais lui il est pour l'europe passoire
il avait encouragé mme merkel à l'époque
c'était en 2015 il était je crois dans
les équipes de monsieur hollande parce
qu'elle avait accueilli pratiquement
d'un million de migrants sera maintenant
il dit qu'il faudrait fermer schengen et
qu' il ya quelque chose à ces notes
différentes notre vraie différence la
sphère du drapeau nicolas sarkozy lui à
l'époque mais deux drapeaux le drapeau
français notre patrie et le drapeau
européen et même à craon lui donne un
signal aux français qui en réalité sa
conception de l'europe d'une europe
fédérale un seul drapeau qui fait
disparaître le drapeau de la france ça
c'est symbolique ça veut dire pas pour
vous il est plus européen que français
il est fédéraliste je suis aussi
européens quel mal macron mais lui veut
les états unis d'europe moi je veux la
france dans l'union il est vraiment un
rond raymond aron avait l'habitude de
dire il décrivait ce fédéralisme comme
un fédéralisme clandestins on ne le dit
jamais mais il avance subrepticement il
avance à l'écart de la délibération des
potes des peuples c'est cette europe
bureaucratique
qui est l'europe fédérale parce que il
ya plusieurs peuples européens et la
seule façon de broyer les peuples c'est
par le technocratisme parle la
bureaucratie et nous ne voulons pas
cette europe nous pensons qu'au
contraire l'europe de demain l'europe de
la conquête lors de l'avenir lord pour
la jeunesse ce sera d'associer en fait
la force de chaque nation et l'europe
est belle parce que il ya eu molière en
france il ya eu got il ya eu cervantès
il y a eu shakespeare qui à terme même
si les anglais nous ont quittés mais on
a une culture européenne que l'on
soutient avec des différences nationales
vous êtes aussi européens qui emmanuel
macron est ce que vous êtes plus
français qu'un manuel m'apprend non je
veux pas dedans je veux pas dire cela
mais nous avons une patrie nous avons
une seule patrie c'est la france
beaucoup de sang a été versé et je pense
que cette patrie là c'est à la fois un
héritage mais c'est aussi un projet un
ce projet qui s'inscrit dans l'europe je
suis contre l'europe fédérale parce que
aujourd'hui aucun peuple européen ne le
souhaite soumettez par référendum cette
idée là soumettez là où peuples
européens et vous n'obtiendrez aucun qui
vous dira oui on va parler de la
présidentielle hier soir valérie
pécresse était l'invité de la nouvelle
émission politique de jean jacques
bourdin une enquête a été ouverte contre
lui hier pour soupçons d'agressions
sexuelles valérie pécresse a maintenu sa
participation à cette fin elle dit avoir
douté un moment mais elle a maintenu à
lui adresser un message lui disons que
la loi du silence s'était finie qu'est
ce que vous avez pensé de cette séquence
c'est très courageux nous en avions
parlé quelques heures auparavant parce
que elle s'interrogeait sur sa
participation compte tenu de cette
information mais attention nous ne
sommes pas dans une société de la
délation la présomption d'innocence elle
vaut pour tous pour un journaliste comme
pour un élu comme pour quelqu'un que
c'est le citoyen simplement on a
toujours rien on gagne toujours à être
sincère et hier elle était sincère elle
elle ne voulait pas cette participation
sans avoir à dire ce mot là pour elle
c'est est important et j'ai et je crois
que ça se sentait cette tonalité cette
sincérité
là aussi ce sera une différence avec
mails macro on parlait tout à l'heure
d'un double langage du en même temps si
c'est un sincérité qu'on lui a souvent
reproché mails macron je pense qu'on a
vu hier une candidate qui est
profondément sincère alors on peut être
d'accord pas d'accord avec des prises de
positions mais c'est elle même avec
beaucoup d'énergie avec de l'empathie de
la bienveillance vis-à-vis des gens et
je crois que cette déclaration qui est
une déclaration sans doute courageuse
mais vous savez quand je lui ai entendu
au départ je me suis dit mais comment ça
va atterrir tout ça non hélas elle a
tenu cette ligne de crête parce qu'elle
était fidèle à ce qu'elle pense au fond
d'elle-même je pense qu'aujourd'hui il
faut ramener de la sincérité de
l'authenticité en politique c'est ce que
veulent les français je pense alors
parlons de ces propositions certaines
font polémique c'est normal dans une
campagne présidentielle notamment
lorsqu'elle propose l'augmentation de
10% des salaires est ce que vous
comprenez les inquiétudes autour de ce
sujet je comprends surtout les
inquiétudes des français les plus
fragiles qui nous l'avait dit d'ailleurs
au tout départ du mouvement des gilet
jaune le problème est que des gens
travaillent ils n'arrivent pas à boucler
les fins de mois est ce que l'on voit
avec l'inflation l'inflation pour le
logement l'inflation pour le carburant
pour se chauffer ça écrase justement les
classes moyennes populaire française
donc il faut y répondre là aussi elle y
répond avec sa bienveillance en
augmentant les salaires mais faut dire
aux français que ça ne peut pas être
toujours l'état qui fait des chèques
c'est impossible donc cela contrepartie
ce sera aussi de mettre une quantité de
travail supérieur comment le fait-on par
exemple en défiscalisant les heures que
nous ferons entre 35 heures et quarante
heures par exemple en rachetant avec 10%
de plus les rtt parce que ça c'est la
spécificité de française l'entreprise
pourra racheter en défiscalisant
désocialisant ces rachats par exemple en
faisant des référendum d'entreprise même
quand il ya pas de syndicats dans une
entreprise pour avaliser vous savez un
référendum il faut que ce soient
authentifiés quand y'a pas un accord de
branche par un syndicat il faut libérer
il faut la démocratie ond d'entreprise
c'est quelque chose d'important et la
retraite à 65 ans ça nous permettra
d'obtenir des marges de manoeuvre pour
financer non seulement le pouvoir
d'achat des inactifs mais surtout aussi
des actifs donc il faut inciter les
patrons à payer mieux aussi nous sommes
nous avons une épreuve une approche
libérale donc l'idée c'est qu'on essaie
de rapprocher le salaire net du salaire
brut en baissant les cotisations
sociales le problème des salariés
français par rapport aux salariés
allemands c'est que par rapport à un
salaire brut il reste plus d'argent dans
la poche du salarié allemand qui n'en
reste dans la poche du salarié français
c'est cet écart qu'on veut réduire mais
c'était carmes je le dis ça ne peut pas
être l'état qui fait des chèques à tout
va ça peut pas être payé par la dette
donc ça doit être payée en mettant plus
de travail sur la table au cours d'une
vie avec le recul de l'âge de la
retraite
au cours d'une année avec le rachat des
rtt et au cours d'une semaine en
laissant libre les entreprises les
salariés aient en défiscalisant les
heures entre 35 heures et quarante
heures dernière question dans un sondage
est sorti hier les français disent
qu'ils trouvent valérie pécresse
courageuse mais pas présidentiable
comment est-ce qu'on remédie à ça
je trouve que ça juste à quoi je jouis l
énergique mais très franchement quand on
a vu l'émission d'hier je lui ai trouvé
une stature présidentielle parce qu'elle
a du tempérament parce que c'est le
courage c'est ce qu'on demande d'abord
un homme ou une femme politique le
courage de ses convictions mais elle en
plus c'est par rapport par exemple à
d'autres concurrents comme marine le pen
ou eric zemmour elle a cet avantage de
pouvoir transformer ses convictions avec
ce courage en vraie solution parce que
derrière elle elle a une équipe et puis
surtout parce que par rapport à eux voté
zemmour voter marine le pen au premier
tour c'est donner plus de chance mm
macro d'être réélu au second tour lui il
n'attend qu'une chose et même à cran
c'est qu' il soit opposé évidemment à
marine le pen eric zemmour ça peu de
chance mais si jamais elle est opposée
avec pécresse il perdra donc moi je
m'adresse à tous ces électeurs et
surtout aux abstentionnistes si vous
voulez que on tourne la page gmail
macron il va falloir voter valérie
pécresse dès le premier tour un dernier
mot sur un sujet qui inquiète
l'effrontée c'est la facture énergétique
les français voient leur facture
énergétique s'envoler le gouvernement
s'engage à contenir la hausse des prix
de l'électricité à 4% pour cela il
demande à edf de vendre à bas prix
l'électricité à ses concurrents ça
représente 8 milliards de pertes pour
l'entreprise environ est ce que c'est
une bonne décision
là on a une décision toute ma cronje
avaler ça va a coûté 8 milliards à edf
alors qu'on veut que edf prépare
l'avenir de la transition énergétique
décarbonés avec de nouvelles centrales
donc on affaiblit edf c'est huit
milliards s'ajoutent à huit autres
milliards sur le bouclier c'est
pratiquement 15 milliards un peu plus de
15 milliards en réalité c'est c'est là
encore un pognon de dingue comme dirait
l'autre et c'est toujours plus de dettes
pourquoi je critique cette politique
parce que quand on est un chef de l'état
il faut une ligne il faut un cap et s'y
tenir or il ya deux ans un peu plus de
deux ans en 2018 mails macron avait dit
qu'il voulait fermer 14 réacteurs
nucléaires il a fermé fessenheim et on
avait une énergie à bon marché et parce
que on ne prépare pas l'avenir on est
obligé de prendre des décisions
précipitamment voilà ça c'est une
politique de gribouille voyez c'est
vraiment parce que quand il s'agit
d'énergie de politique énergétique et
donc de pouvoir d'achat il faut assurer
une prise de décision politique sur le
très long terme c'est ce que grâce au
général de gaulle et au président qu'ils
ont suivi la france disposait d'un
avantage compétitif extraordinaire on
paie 2 par rapport à l'allemagne deux
fois moins en termes de tarifs et on est
souverain beaucoup plus indépendant les
allemands deviennent dépendants du gaz
russe et en plus l'allemagne et même est
tellement plus de quantité de gaz à
effet de serre que nous alors que nous
on a une énergie décarbonée d'obtenir un
cap foyer et je pense que pour faire les
pécresse pour la prochaine président de
la république c'est ça qu'il faut tirer
de l'expérience des mails macron quand
on zigzague en permanence ne peut pas y
avoir de cap et donc il peut pas y avoir
une france plus forte merci beaucoup
merci bruno retailleau d'avoir été notre
invité ce matin
[Musique]